un collégien prenant les transports
publics pourraient avoir besoin de
quatre masques pour une journée complète
ce qui se traduirait par une dépense
pour une famille avec les masques des
parents de plusieurs dizaines d'euros
par mois est cependant potentiellement
de nombreux mois si nous avions si nous
avons bien compris que les seces et les
associations pour intervenir pour les
personnes en situation de précarité
l'état at-il prévu une aide pour les
ménages salariés modestes pour qui cet
achat représentera une charge importante
aux risques de l'utilisation de masques
périmés ou ne répondant pas aux normes
cette aide pourrait par exemple prendre
la forme d'une réévaluation de la prime
d'activité et ainsi être facilement
distribués par les caf pour vous
répondre
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur merci de cette
question je voudrais apporter la réponse
la plus claire possible à la question
que vous avez posé une réponse à une
question vous n'avez pas posée mais que
laquelle vous avez sûrement tellement
pensé qu'il me semble nécessaire de
pouvoir préciser les choses en la
matière comme disait l'autre c'est pas
votre question mais c'est quand même ma
réponse aux prédécesseurs monsieur le
premier ministre vous j'en ai beaucoup
le président monsieur le sénateur donc
sur la question de la distribution des
masques aux collégiens nous l'avons dit
les masques seront le port du masque
sera obligatoire pour les professeurs
bien entendu quels que soient les
niveaux d'enseignement et à partir de la
6e 6e et 5e au moment de la rentrée des
classes pour les collégiens bien entendu
c'est l'éducation nationale
l'état qui fournira les masques le sens
de mon propos hier c'était de dire et
c'est important de bien comprendre que
s'agissant des collégiens évidemment
l'état fournira les masques mais que nos
concitoyens vont fabriquer des masques
vont disposer de masques que certains
acteurs les employeurs les associations
des collectivités territoriales vont
mettre à leur disposition et vont
acheter des masques ils vont les acheter
dans la grande distribution dans les
pharmacies dans tous les réseaux on peut
acquérir cet instrument qui sera parfois
obligatoire dans certains cas parfois
recommandé et dont le visage ne sera dès
lors pas nécessairement obligatoire
sur cette question je veux vous rassurer
dire les choses le plus clairement
possible sur la question que vous avez
failli poser à laquelle je tiens à
répondre
qui est qui étaient déjà contenues dans
mon discours d'hier mais je n'ai pas
forcément été suffisamment précis où je
veux aller peut-être encore un peu plus
loin que ce que j'ai dit hier c'est à
dire l'accompagnement par l'état des
collectivités territoriales qui vont
faire l'acquisition de masques pour
aider à fournir l'ensemble de notre
population en masque à compter du 11 mai
j'ai indiqué hier que pour encourager
cette acquisition général de masque dès
lors que nous avions la certitude que
nous pouvions équipes et les soignants
dans la durée l'état s'est engagé à
rembourser ou à accompagner les
collectivités à hauteur de 50% des
masques qu'ils achèteraient le cadre
d'un prix de référence à compter du
moment où je faisais cette annonce mais
après avoir écouté ce matin les
associations d'élus locaux que nous
avons rencontrés avec beaucoup des
membres du gouvernement
après les avoir entendues développer un
certain nombre d'arguments je crois que
il les plus justes de d'étendre ce
dispositif à toutes les commandes de
masques passé depuis que le président de
la république a évoqué la date du 11 mai
parce que dès lors que le président
alain public évoque le 13 avril la date
du 11 mai il me semble que toutes les
commandes qui ont été passées dans le
par les collectivités theuriau par les
collectivités territoriales
pardon à partir du 13 avril doivent
bénéficier du même du même
accompagnement et de l'âme humaine
encouragements je dirais que celui que
l'état propose proposé hier par ma voix
hier à la tribune
donc voilà les choses sont claires
s'agissant des collégiens l'état
fournira et s'agissant de l'ensemble des
commandes passées par les collectivités
territoriales pour équiper les
populations de masquer l'état
accompagnera pour les commandes qui sont
passés à compter du 13